2018 musste sich facebook chef mark
zuckerberg vor mehr oder weniger gut
informierten senatoren in den usa
verantworten
der grund war die beeinflussung der
letzten us mal mit hilfe von facebook
daten durch die firma cambridge
analytiker und auch wenn das für manche
senatoren überraschend war ist es
mittlerweile selbstverständlich dass
viele silicon valley konzerne ihr geld
mit unseren daten verdienen gesammelte
und verkaufte daten sind auch der grund
dass unsere online erfahrung
mittlerweile so individuell auf uns
zugeschnitten ist
algorithmen beobachten ständig was wir
online machen und auch wenn das
praktisch sein kann und stu vielleicht
nicht zu verbergen hast geht datenschutz
uns alle etwas an
denn mit deinen und meinen daten können
unternehmen wie cambridge analytica
programme schreiben und trainieren die
die welt verändern
im sinne des höchstbietenden vor allem
messenger apps sind für große firmen
aber auch hacker ein gefundenes fressen
die schlechte nachricht ist dass solche
geschäftsmodelle wohl erstmal nicht
verschwinden werden
die gute nachricht ist dass wir eine
entscheidung haben es gibt immer mehr
messenger die mit einer ende zu ende
verschlüsselung ausgestattet sind
aber reicht das worauf muss man beim
essen achten und was ist denn jetzt
wirklich der sicherste messenger darum
geht es heute bei doktor watson
[Musik]
russische behörden blockieren den
messenger-dienst telegramm
es ist wie eine art sender den man
unbewusst immer bei sich trägt
[Musik]
an dieser stelle möchte ich erst mal
erwähnen dass wir natürlich von keine
messenger dienst bezahlt werden die
ergebnisse dieses videos basieren auf
unsere unabhängigen recherche gesponsert
ist das video quasi von euch auch patron
unterstützen und schon über 50 leute mit
kleinen monatlichen spenden dafür könnt
ihr manche videos gesehen und hab noch
einfluss auf die themenwahl der nächsten
videos danke an euch dass ihr dieses
video hier möglich gemacht hat ok als
erstes haben wir uns whatsapp angeschaut
denn die app wird hier in deutschland
mit abstand am meisten verwendet laut
aktuellen zahlen benutzen
96 prozent aller deutschen die messenger
verwenden whatsapp wie gut ist also die
app die wir fast jeden tag benutzen um
mit unseren freunden verwandten und
partnern zu kommunizieren
nun seid 2014 gehört whatsapp zu
facebook
seit 2016 dürfen laut den
nutzungsbedingungen der app alle
nutzerdaten mit allen anderen diensten
aus dem hause facebook geteilt werden
facebook erhält zum beispiel eurem
profil namen profilbild den startschuss
die handynummer und eure e mail adresse
falls ihr diese verknüpft habt aber
nicht nur eure daten werden von facebook
gespeichert auch die infos aus auch im
adressbuch also auch daten von personen
die gar keine facebook angebote nutzen
selbst wenn es dir also nicht so wichtig
ist dass facebook auf deine daten
zugriff hat gibst du indirekt daten von
deinen freunden weiter und laut den agbs
bei facebook alle diese gesammelten
daten verkaufen
zumindest bis vor kurzem denn ende juni
2020 ist ein eilantrag beim landgericht
düsseldorf eingegangen dass facebook in
zukunft nicht mehr einfach daten ohne
zustimmung sammeln darf der konzern hat
jetzt mehrere monate zeit um sich ein
konzept zu überlegen und vorzustellen
dass die nutzer selber entscheiden lässt
wie viel und welche daten erteilen
möchte
immerhin sind die jets bei whatsapp mit
einer ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung
abgesichert laut dem protokoll dass
facebook hilfe nutzt sind also eure
nachrichten anhänge und auch
sprachnachrichten nur für euch und eure
gesprächspartner sichtbar
leider hat die sache aber einen haken
obwohl mark zuckerberg abstreitet dass
die facebook app auf chat inhalte
zugreifen kann existiert zumindest die
möglichkeit in ios zum beispiel sind
apps voneinander getrennt und können die
daten von anderen apps nicht einsehen
außer sie sind vom selben entwickler
innerhalb derselben app können apps
einen gemeinsamen ordner nutzen seitdem
whatsapp anteil von facebook ist kann
die app also in dem verzeichnis
group.com punkt facebook punkt family
daten austauschen
auf einem entsperrten smartphone lassen
sich so von facebook telefonnummern
namen zeitstempel und eben auch die
nachrichten selber aus der lokalen
datenbank im klartext auslesen
das heißt natürlich nicht dass das
gerade auf deinem smartphone passiert
dieses schlupfloch in der ende zu ende
verschlüsselung gibt es aber wie es hier
in zukunft weitergeht das ist noch nicht
ganz klar aber noch letztes jahr wurde
offen über pläne gesprochen alle
facebook messenger services
zusammenzulegen
obwohl diese unterschiedliche
sicherheitsstandards erfüllen es war
prophezeite werk das die zukunft
verschlüsselt und privat ist dass
facebook geschäftsmodell ist es aber
nicht
ein punkt ist außerdem noch wichtig
selbst wenn facebook die wahrheit sagt
und nicht eure nachrichten selber liest
sie sehen immer dass ihr etwas schreibt
allein aus der tatsache dass du
regelmäßig mit einer bestimmten freundin
schreibt oder dass du jemand anderem
immer nur zum geburtstag gratuliert kann
ein algorithmus etwas lernen
facebook hat außerdem schon mittels ip
rausfinden können dass leute am selben
ort übernachten
daraus können sie dann natürlich auch
ihre schlüsse ziehen
für viele leute die whatsapp nicht mehr
benutzen wollen ist telegramm eine
alternative telegramm und auch telegramm
ich weiß nicht genau ausspricht ist
gratis
laut eigenen angaben für immer für die
anmeldung benötigte telegram eure
telefonnummer und schätzt werden in
einer cloud gespeichert das hat den
vorteil dass ihr selbst wenn euer handy
aus ist telegramm nutzen könnt sie gibt
es aber einen haken chats werden nur in
der cloud gespeichert wenn sie nicht
verschlüsselt sind
denn das ist der standard bei telegramm
während sogar whatsapp standardmäßig
jeden chat und jede gruppe verschlüsselt
muss man mit telegramm dafür extra einen
privaten chat eröffnen also quasi wie
ein inkognito fenster im browser
das ist unpraktisch und während
telegramm sich auf ihrer website als
super sicherer messenger darstellt ist
es eben nur halbwegs sicher wenn ihr die
funktion selber für jeden staat einzeln
aktivieren müsst ist ein sicherer chat
erst einmal angelegt dann wird dieser
mit der hauseigenen
verschlüsselungstechnik geschützt
experten und andere entwickler haben
sich aber schon öffentlich darüber
geäußert dass diese verschlüsselung
fehlerhaft ist und unnötige
sicherheitsrisikos bietet außerdem ist
die serverstruktur von telegramm
proprietär das heißt die angaben von
telegramm selber über die cloud
speicherung die verschlüsselung oder die
sicherheit lassen sich nicht überprüfen
da sie nicht offen einsehbar sind
deswegen wurde auch das ganze marketing
von telegram als sicherer messenger
schon mehrfach in frage gestellt die
bürgerrechtsbewegung in hongkong hat zum
beispiel sorgen geäußert dass
informationen über demonstrationen und
demonstranten von telegramm an die
lokalen und chinesischen behörden durch
gesichert sind und auch die strukturen
hinter telegramm sind noch ein bisschen
unklar
laut eigenen angaben ist telegramm eine
nichtkommerzielle organisation mit sitz
in dubai
das unternehmen war aber auch schon auf
den seychellen registriert und einige
entwickler sitzen wohl in sankt
petersburg nach einer adresse oder einem
impressum sucht man auf jeden fall
vergeblich die beiden gründer haben
vorher das populäre russischen netzwerk
vk gegründet das ist so was wie das
russische facebook
wenn euch die app also zu dubios ist
dann könntet ihr auf prima umsteigen bei
frimo müsst ihr keine persönlichen
angaben machen
hier werdet ihr mit einer zufällig
generierten id ausgestattet über die
euch andere finden können
und prima speichert eine telefonnummer
oder e-mail-adresse nur auf wunsch laut
eigenen angaben verschlüsselt verbindet
ihr aber eure telefonnummer mit prima
dann geht die ein sicherheitsrisiko ein
deutscher telefonnummern haben nur
begrenzt unterschiedliche zahlen
kombinationen so könnte sich ein hacker
theoretisch mit eurer nummer als euch
ausgeben und andere jets gelangen
glücklicherweise ist eine telefonnummer
bei prima aber wie gesagt optional
wenn ihr also einfach darauf verzichtet
dann seid ihr auf der sicheren seite
primär selber empfiehlt dass sie aus
sicherheitsgründen freunde am besten
über den persönlichen qr-code essen
sollte
das klappt bei näheren umfeld natürlich
super und eure bekanntschaft oder
familie aber weiter weg dann müsst ihr
auf andere methoden zurückgreifen
über e mail oder telefon nummer könnt
ihr kontakte finden die selber ihre e
mail oder telefon nummer mit ihrer prima
idee verbunden haben
hierzu werden die daten aus dem eigenen
adressbuch aber nicht dauerhaft
gespeichert sondern ein weg
verschlüsselt und nach einem abgleich
wieder gelöscht so werden die daten von
unbeteiligten freunden auf den servern
hinterlegt zusätzlich könnt ihr sogar
ein passwort festlegen das optional nach
jedem start der app oder nach einem
festgelegten zeitraum in der app
abgefragt wird
außerdem könnt ihr sogar einstellen dass
alle daten nach zehn falschen eingaben
unwiderruflich gelöscht werden
besonders wichtig bei der sicherheit von
messenger diensten ist auch der standort
der server ist dieser zum beispiel in
den usa
dann ist das ein sicherheitsrisiko dort
gelten sehr lockere datenschutzgesetz
und prima hat seine server aber in der
schweiz dort greifen vergleichbare
datenschutz standards wie die eu
datenschutz verordnung
das ist schon mal besser als die usa
aber immer noch nicht optimal die
datenschutzrechtlichen vorteile von
frima haben aber ihren preis
die app kostet 399 denn frima ist wie
facebook ein gewinnorientiertes
unternehmen
wir haben keine sicherheit dass prima in
zukunft nicht werbung schaltet oder eure
daten verkaufen muss um gewinn zu machen
und machen wir uns nichts vor für viele
ist am ende entscheidend welchen dienst
familie und freunde nutzen und ein
preisschild macht es prima da nicht
einfach
komplett gratis und mit ein paar extra
sicherheitsfeatures ist dafür
sydney während ihr bei prima ohne e mail
oder handynummer auskommt gibt das
signal ohne telefonnummer überhaupt
nichts auch ein nutzername wird verlangt
hier kann man aber einfach irgendeinen
pseudonym angeben oder sogar einfach nur
eine moschee auf dein adressbuch hat
signal ohne dein erlaubnis auch keinen
zugriff und wie whatsapp und prima sind
auch hier alle chats
ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung signal ist
so etwas wie das lieblingskind aller
datenschützer denn die app ist bekannt
für ihr zero knowledge prinzip das heißt
dass der betreiber keine informationen
darüber hat wer wann mit wem worüber
spricht
umgesetzt wird das durch die
ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung kontakte
werden nicht im klartext auf den server
der betreiber geladen und profilbild und
ansteigen namen sind nicht von sich
selber sondern nur von gesprächspartnern
sichtbar
hinzu kommt das signal komplett open
source ist im gegensatz zu whatsapp und
sogar frima ist der komplette kauf von
sydney offen zugänglich man kann ihn
sich einfach auf die tap durchlesen und
war deswegen dass das ganze sicher ist
man da nichts versteckt ist leider weiß
man natürlich nicht ob das auch der code
ist den man dann später im app store
unterlegt aber das ist ja schon mal
besser als den code überhaupt nicht zu
gesicht zu bekommen
bei prima sind nur teile des codes
lesbar und bei whatsapp ist überhaupt
nichts offen verfügbar
ein weiteres cooles feature ist dass man
mit signal auch nachrichten mit
selbstzerstörung senden kann
das schützt euch natürlich nicht
vorsätzliche feature wenn ihr zum
beispiel passwörter oder pin codes
verwenden wollte sein feature hat
übrigens auch telegramm single wird von
der gemeinnützigen stiftung entwickelt
und betrieb erklärtes ziel der stiftung
ist es für alle menschen den freien
meinungsaustausch in geschützter
privatsphäre bereitzustellen 2018 hat
sie von whatsapp gründer drei nächten
ein startkapital von 50 millionen us
dollar erhalten
manche sehen das als problem ich denke
eher dass red bull nach dem verkauf von
whatsapp an facebook ein schlechtes
gewissen hatte und etwas wieder
gutmachen wollte auch edward snowden
selber benutzte laut eigener aussage
täglich signal
okay das sind jetzt nur vier messenger
dienste gewesen aber natürlich gibt es
noch viele viele weitere mehr
war ja zum beispiel ist ähnlich wie
stilsicher und open source und außerdem
für privatpersonen kostenlos
wie will man sich durch business kunden
und teams finanzieren leider geht die
firma seit kurzem einem us unternehmen
und hat schon die ags geändert um
nutzerdaten zu teilen denn es notwendig
sein
was auch immer das heißt auf secure
messaging apps punkt com könnt ihr euch
eine übersicht verschiedener messenger
anschauen und wie sicher sie sind okay
aber welcher ist jetzt der beste manager
nun das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab
wie deine einstellung ist
manche sagen dass man den
gewinnorientierten prima er vertrauen
kann weil das unternehmen dahinter
unabhängig ist und sich durch die app
verkäufe finanzieren
sie sind quasi nur den nutzern gegenüber
verpflichtet aber das kann auch ein
nachteil sein
er wird von einer gmbh betrieben und die
kosten werden nicht ewig bei 3 eur 99
bleiben können
irgendwann müssen wahrscheinlich monats
abos oder eben werbung korn
ich bin persönlich eher fern von sydney
das hat höchste datenschutzstandards ist
open source und nicht kommerziell
orientiert was ich persönlich besser
finde außerdem ist es kostenlos das ist
besonders wichtig da wir uns alle einig
sind dass sap hier von allen diensten am
schlechtesten abschneidet und wir so
schnell wie möglich umsteigen sollten
denn messenger sind untereinander nicht
kompatibel und deswegen wird es immer
ein marktführer geben müssen bei dem die
meisten leute sind ein kostenloser
service hat da mehr chancen als ein
kostenpflichtiger leider witzige in
amerika entwickelt und unterliegt damit
den us-amerikanischen
datenschutzgesetzen und die stehen
gerade auf wackeligen beinen
übrigens selbst wenn ihr den daten
sparsamsten und sichersten messenger
welt seid ihr nicht zu 100 prozent für
überwachung sicher
denn wenn die polizei benötigt hält darf
sie euch in der eu anzapfen und die nsa
hat sich schon lange darauf
spezialisiert nachrichten abzustreifen
bevor sie überhaupt verschlüsselt werden
whatsapp ist kein problem für die
behörden und wie es bei telegramm und
prima oder signal aussieht das kann
keiner so richtig sagen auch hacker kaum
mit genug aufwand an eure daten anfang
des jahres wurde amazon ceo jeff bezos
vermutlich vom saudischen kronprinzen
salman gehackt und das natürlich werden
die meisten von uns nicht gehackt es
lohnt sich aber trotzdem vorsichtig zu
sein und darüber nachzudenken wie wir
mit wem kommunizieren und was wir mit
wem teilen wollen wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert wie unternehmen wie zum
beispiel facebook eure daten weiter
verwenden und algorithmen schreiben die
euch teilweise besser kennen als ihr
selbst dann schaut euch gerne dieses
video hier von mir an
ein großes dankeschön geht an daniel von
schimpansen und cedric von dem of use
tutorials die man bei diesem video hier
geholfen haben wenn ihr euch für
anonymität im internet interessiert dann
könnt ihr euch gerne eine ganze playlist
von dem off des tutorials hier ansehen
ansonsten immer bleibt wachsam bleibt
neugierig erster blick